well the last 24 hours have been some of
the most consequential that we have had
in months we first heard from the
current uh attorney general
merrick garland that no one is above the
law that he is open to prosecuting
former president donald trump
but then in addition to that we learned
based on a very interesting report from
the washington post that donald trump is
currently
under criminal investigation by the
justice department this was the question
is the justice department criminally
investigating donald trump have they
paid attention to the january 6
committee or to what's going on in
georgia or to whatever else and done
their own investigation and determined
this is worthy not necessarily of
charges but of criminal investigation
and the news that broke over the last 24
hours is that the answer is yes
we're going to look at both of these
things i was going to lead with garland
but garland being open to prosecuting
trump is irrelevant if there's no probe
it now has been uh revealed that there
is indeed a probe washington post report
justice department investigating trump's
actions in january sixth criminal probe
people familiar with the probe said
investigators are examining the former
president's conversations and have
seized the phone records of top aides
understand
this is already historic it is not
typical that a president leaves office
and then is under federal criminal
investigation now it may go to absolute
nothing the this investigation may end
up in the toilet
uh flushed 10 to 15 times but this is
already an unprecedented and unique
situation the justice department is
investigating trump's actions as part of
its criminal probe of efforts to
overturn the 2020 election according to
four people familiar with the matter
prosecutors who were questioning
witnesses before a grand jury including
two top aides to vice president pence
have asked in recent days about
conversations with trump his lawyers and
others in his inner circle who sought to
substitute trump allies for certified
electors from some states joe biden won
this is the fake elector scam
um
the prosecutors have asked hours of
detailed questions about meetings trump
led in december of 2020 and january 2021
his pressure campaign on pence to
overturn the election and what
instructions trump gave his lawyers and
advisers about fake electors
and sending electors back to the states
the people said some of the questions
focused directly on trump's on the
extent of trump's involvement in the
fake elector effort led by his outside
lawyers including john eastman and rudy
giuliani
uh this is major folks
and it appears that a lot of the focus
is on the fake elector scheme
the belief among some legal experts is
that that's probably the easiest one to
prove
but it is all very much related
generally to trump's attempt to
overthrow the government and to install
himself the guy who did not win the
illegitimate
wouldn't even to say an illegitimate
president he just wouldn't he wasn't the
president he didn't win
um the article goes on to say
justice department investigators in
april received phone records of key
officials and aides in the trump
administration including mark meadows as
chief of staff
that effort is another indicator of how
expansive the january 6 probe had become
well before
the hearings in june and july this is
another really important question
or answer i guess we would better say
we were wondering
not only is slash was there a probe
but
did the probe only start because of the
january 6 committee hearings and it
appears that the answer is no there was
actually a criminal probe of trump that
started well before that um
what do we know about some of the
build-up to all of this well jacqueline
alemany who uh works for the washington
post and was part of breaking this story
appeared on msnbc and talked about it
listen to this that's exactly right
willie we've reported that prosecutors
who have
recently brought in people like greg
jacobs and and mark short uh and
potentially more we just
you know people were not we might not be
aware of just yet but people who were
very close to mike pence had first-hand
accounts and were witness to the
pressure campaign being applied on him
to overturn the results of the election
and we're also in the room for other
meetings involving some of the
constitutional schemes being put forth
by trump allies people like john eastman
before the president they were asked
about those interactions they were asked
about meetings in december of 2021 and
january of 2020
in december of 2020 and january of 2021
we also know that they were asked
specifically about the pressure being
put on mike pence according to
sources
and we also know that these phone
records that have been newly reported
and obtained by the justice department
included phone records from
top trump aides and mark meadows as well
someone else who was also in the room
for a lot of these uh really
explosive uh and meetings that have
recently garnered a lot of scrutiny by
all right so the point here that i can
only make uh a limited number of times
in an hour program but i think needs to
be made is
we all have been
some degree desensitized by these last
many years
uh and i include myself in that but this
is not normal this is extraordinary
these are extraordinary times that we
are living in the former president is
under criminal investigation by the
following administration's justice
department now what could be the
possible crimes i've been reading up on
this this morning as a non-lawyer who
spoke to some lawyers there are three
possibilities the easiest to prove would
likely be conspiracy to defraud the
united states this would be over the
fake electors sending fake electors
would be committing a fraud as trump
says on the on the united states other
possible crimes obstruction of an
official proceeding now there are lots
of variations of this
but
um the one being looked at by the
january 6th committee um seems to be
1512 c which theoretically carries up to
20 years in prison i don't expect that
that's ever going to be trump's future
uh partially because he won't live 20
years and then also seditious conspiracy
is possible but again when we anything
with the word sedition in it
the bar to prove criminal intent is a
difficult one to overcome and it's sort
of related to why i know i've said this
before you don't often see perjury
charges even though people do lie in
court all the time
um and we will just have to follow it
and see now if you weren't sure about
the consequential nature of the midterm
election in 2022 and of course the
presidential in 2024
if you did think that those elections
were important before
they are absolutely above and beyond
important now trump got away
two different impeachments without
conviction because republicans had the
senate
you
have to understand that if control goes
back to republicans in 2022
a lot of this stuff is completely dead
in the water now might charges be
brought against trump before that maybe
i don't think so i don't know
but i would expect donald trump to
announce his candidacy very soon he
believes that that would be a way to
shield himself from the criminal probe
now if you want me to be honest if i
look at my crystal ball
i expect that even if there is such an
investigation at some point we will hear
there is really no precedent for
charging a former president of the
united states i know i'm being
pessimistic but that's my crystal ball
but uh the next question becomes
would trump announcing his candidacy do
anything to shield him here and merit
garland says the answer is no all right
so next part of this incredible story
part one is trump under criminal
investigation part two a number of
statements from the attorney general
merrick garland over the last week or 10
days indicating a willingness
at least theoretically to prosecute a
former president okay we have been
waiting for these signals the first
signal is the following here is an
interview with lester holt that merrick
garland did yesterday you said in no
uncertain terms the other day that no
one is above the law
that said
the indictment of a former president of
perhaps candidate for president
would arguably tear the country apart is
that your concern as you make your
decision down the road here i really
hope that's not his concern
do you have to think about things like
that look we pursue
justice without fear or favor
we intend to hold everyone
anyone who was criminally responsible
for events surrounding january 6
for any attempt to interfere with the
lawful transfer of power from one
administration to another
accountable that's what we do
we don't pay any attention to
other uh issues with respect to that so
donald trump were to become a candidate
for president again that would not
change your schedule or how you move
forward or don't move forward
say again that
we will hold accountable anyone who is
criminally responsible
for attempting to interfere with the
transfer legitimate lawful transfer of
power from one administration to the
next so that is quite clear from merit
garland that is quite clear and there
has been an increased increasingly
noticeable shift in this direction now
on july 20th this was about a week ago
merrick garland also made very clear and
that's the statement that was referenced
no person is above the law also believed
to be a signal about what may be coming
we are entering a zone here where
if there are charges brought against a
former president related to january 6
doj could be accused of playing politics
how
is the department how are you weighing
that also do you think that there is a
constitutional question or alter about
whether you charge a former president or
actions allegedly taken during his term
separately
jalen walker okay let's watch her i'll
okay look
no person
is above the law in this country
nothing stops us
no i don't know how to say that again
no person is above the law in this
country i can't say anything more
clearly than that
there is nothing in the principles of
prosecution in any other factors which
prevent us from investigating anyone
anyone who's criminally responsible
for for
an attempt to undo a democratic election
so that was the first signal
that
there was something going on and then of
course over the last 24 hours we have
learned trump under criminal
investigation by the federal
government the justice department a
major major deal which we will continue
to follow now again
i don't want i don't want to be negative
i don't want to be pessimistic
but
do i really see charges announced
against donald trump by merrick garland
i don't know that i do i don't know
that i do but i will of course concede
i think it is more likely today than at
any point over the last two three years
during which i've been asked about it
again and again and again let me know
where you are you can find me on twitter
at deepakman what do you expect at this
point and do the last 24 hours change
your opinion
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show may not be like
other programs that you listen to or
that you watch we actually depend on the
support of our audience to do what we do
and the primary source of that support
is the membership program which you can
sign up for at joinpackman.com we do an
extra show every day called the bonus
show for our members we also provide a
commercial free audio feed and a
commercial free video feed
for our members of the daily show
usually available five to six hours
earlier than when the show goes out to
everybody
sign up at joinpacman.com you can use
the coupon code obama obama obama
to get a discount also many other coupon
codes floating around there in the ether
but joinpakman.com is the one and only
place to sign up well a huge deal was
made yesterday about a speech from the
failed former president donald trump in
washington dc it was billed as his
triumphant and defiant return returned
to washington dc of course it didn't
quite go as planned number one it
happened under the cloud uh figuratively
of a criminal federal investigation into
the former president we learned about
that yesterday as donald trump was
giving his speech almost quite literally
the speech was for the america first
policy institute this is one of these
non-profit political nonprofits
and it was created
essentially around trump trump was
inaugurated in 2017 he would talk about
america first then they created the
america first policy institute it's sort
of supposed to appear to be kind of a
think tank it's just a wacky wacky
organization and trump gave this much
promoted speech and it was whacked trump
went full deep state conspiracy theories
trump pretended to be transgender it was
a complete and utter implosion and we
are going to look at and this is one of
the most deranged speeches that donald
trump has ever given and it's deranged
for two reasons number one
the speech lacks all context for what
happened during trump's presidency and
for the fact that he's currently under
criminal investigation it's sort of like
a just a fantasy world speech
number two
it is stunning the degree of
authoritarianism that a supposed small
government movement now casually demands
and we will get to that part of the
speech as well
part of it is trump saying we just got
to make it easy to fire people and here
he pulls out the deep state conspiracy
theory in the swamp and root out the
deep state we need to make it much
easier to fire rogue bureaucrats who are
deliberately undermining democracy
or at a minimum just want to keep their
jobs they want to hold on to their jobs
congress should pass historic reforms
empowering the president to ensure that
any bureaucrat who is corrupt
incompetent or unnecessary for the job
can be told did you ever hear this
you're fired get out you're fired
have to do it
deep state deep state
deep state is a conspiracy theory of a
sort of clandestine network of actors
involved in the federal government
involved in industry
involved in high-level finance and they
operate as a kind of hidden government
specifically deep state is sort of a
trump-aligned conspiracy theory but the
idea of a shadow government that is
really pulling the strings that's a very
very old conspiracy theory it's often
highly anti-semitic involving that it's
actually the jews pulling the strings
there are many versions of it
and
trump has bought into it full this is a
this is straight up conspiracy theory
whack job stuff
often there will be some kernel of truth
to hang on to and the kernel of truth is
people with money tend to have power in
the united states that is true and it
has been blown up
into the supposed anti-trump deep cover
conspiracy theory and trump just openly
talking about it now now trump also
regularly overtly transphobic now during
his speeches he did it here as well and
here in this clip donald trump pretends
to lift weights first impersonating i
guess what he believes to be
a quote real female weight lifter
and then impersonating a trans weight
lifter this is a staple now of trump's
speeches kevin's saying he can lift it i
don't know about that kevin but that's a
lot 218 pounds and she got over that
weight and she was gonna break it they
put a half an ounce here half little
tiny ring on top of these big
barbells dumbbells
and they go and she went like this and
she got a break
stood for 11 years
and a mother and father are screaming
you got it
you got it darling i'm so proud of my
girl
she couldn't do it
and then
this guy comes along
he's named alice
[Applause]
and he looks at the way
world record world record
we could have put another couple of
hundred pounds on i think he would have
lifted him
so regularly misgendering people
ridiculing trans athletes by the way
inventing scenarios that are completely
imaginary and this is now
overtly
acceptable
in these contexts this is this america
first policy institute it's supposed to
be
more of a buttoned up serious policy
think tank arm of the delusional
trumpist maga america first nonsense and
it's not turning out that way because
trump is on stage pretending to be trans
now continuing the horrible
authoritarianism trump announces his
plan for the homeless and it's basically
to create tent cities where you put
homeless people in tents all kinds from
all places lying along the roads that's
without the tents
and then you look at the tents and the
homeless
and you say what's happening to this
great bastion
perhaps some people will not like
hearing this but the only way you're
going to remove the hundreds of
thousands of people and maybe throughout
our nation millions of people we're
talking now two things here one they are
now also selling gold coins
alongside trump's speech on newsmax and
secondly understand the absurdity trump
bemoans the horrible nature of homeless
people living in tents in cities and his
solution is make homeless people live in
tents outside of cities that's the
solution talking about
and help make our cities clean safe and
beautiful again
is open up large parcels of inexpensive
land and the outer reaches of the cities
bring medical professionals
including doctors psychiatrists
psychologists right all the medical
professionals trump ignored for for
years during covet rehab specialists
build permanent bathrooms and other
facilities make them good make them hard
you need your sink
you need your shower
and you need your third third element of
the bathroom but build them fast
and create
thousands and thousands of high quality
tents which can be done in one day one
day and you have to move people out now
some people say oh that's so horrible no
what's horrible
is what's happening now right so trump
really displeased with all of the
homeless people living in tents in
cities we've got to do something for
them we really do so we're going to move
them to tents
outside of the cities and the tents will
be a little bit better and we will have
doctors there uh really really wild
authoritarian stuff
trump then of course going through his
pity me part of the speech where he said
he's been treated even worse than
richard nixon i guess that's the point
he's trying to make
who else could have taken this
you know think of it nixon went through
not even one impeachment
and i think he always regretted that he
didn't fight
but uh people uh
it's been a very interesting period of
time yeah just treated so terribly trump
you know subjected to multiple
impeachments that even nixon didn't go
through that at another point in the
speech donald trump claimed that we
charge the country
25 000
for each person that comes in illegally
i assume he means we build a source
country so like if a mexican person
comes in illegally we bill mexico for 25
grand all of the bad ones and the police
know almost immediately who the bad ones
are and that we could do and that we can
do fast and easy at the same time we
should implement a bond system and a
financial penalty so that anyone who
comes to our country on a temporary visa
and fails to depart suffers significant
financial consequences and we take the
money away from the country we charge
the country 25 000 each for each person
that comes in illegally notice that
there's almost no policy during these
bizarre speeches but when you get
something that sounds like policy it's
number one completely absurd and
obviously unworkable diplomatically and
also the crowd collapse because they
don't seem to know any better at all um
at another moment donald trump talked
about democratic congressman adam schiff
and trump's increasingly focused on
schiff's personal appearance and the
shape of schiff's head referring to it
regularly now to be watermelon shaped
and it's this
think of this these are hacks and thugs
through the same people that we've been
dealing with for four years same people
and it's the
very people who
perpetrated the lies that i was an agent
of russia like adam shifty chef and
others
who are standing before the same
microphone same thing they get out and
they say oh our country
is suffering so badly because and he
knows the whole thing is a hoax
i said this the other day he knew russia
russia was a hoax him hillary clinton
the dnc the democrats
and he stood pompously before
microphones
his head as you know i feel shaped like
a watermelon
trump's head is really small by the way
he's quite an unattractive man
now see they'll get me in trouble for
that kellyanne because by saying he's
unattractive they'll say that's a
horrible thing to say
but he said slightly worse about
me
right and it's right he did even worse
okay so
then we go into the full authoritarian
part of the speech where trump again has
this almost like a wet dream of sending
military into cities to quote restore
order despite the governor's wishes all
of a sudden not super concerned with
states rights where there is a true and
total breakdown of law and order where
citizens most basic rights have been
violated then the federal government can
and should send the national guard to
restore order and secure the peace
without having to wait for the approval
of some governor
that thinks it's politically incorrect
the party of states rights says we
should be allowed to send in the
military whenever we want
[Applause]
when governors refuse to protect their
people we need to bring in what's
necessary anyway we have to go beyond
the governor
another 60 people were shot
think of this it's not even possible
were shot in chicago over the weekend
yes in africa with many many with
firearms that whose providence is
originally
purchases in the neighboring state of
indiana with very lacks gun laws
afghanistan for 18 months not one of our
soldiers
was killed
and they had that number of people shot
in chicago over the weekend think of it
and he died by the way many died
when that many are shot
a lot are gonna die and this is constant
in chicago and this cannot go on anymore
every other approach has been considered
and tried yeah you know the thing that
hasn't been tried is actually dealing
with the guns but trump wants to send in
the troops very very small government
states rights conservative okay last
couple things after to go back to the
trans part tr anti-trans is such a big
part now of trump's speeches when trump
finishes up a rant attacking trans youth
and trans athletes he says his idea for
winning with a basketball team would be
to convince lebron james to be a woman
so unfair
[Applause]
it's so unfair
and i'll tell you what if i were ever
i'd be the greatest
women's basketball coach in history
because i don't like lebron james i like
michael jordan much better but
i
whoa
but i'd go up to lebron james it doesn't
matter say lebron did you ever have any
desire to be a woman
because what i'd love you to do is star
on my team that i'm building up i will
have the greatest team in history
they'll never lose
nobody will come within 70 points of
this team
now we have to change that and we have
to make it okay to talk about it you
know the young lady i was talking about
is afraid to talk about it she's shunned
and she's cancelled when she talks about
it yep so there's trump's big idea for
basketball and then lastly just maybe
the dumbest part of the speech
altogether trump rants about windshield
wipers true i said i can't talk about it
i complained i said i did too good a job
i did too good a job that's like
obsolescence you know a windshield wiper
for those of you i used to drive cars
haven't been driving too many lately but
for those for those of you that complain
you buy a windshield wiper right
and it lasts for one year then it
doesn't work anymore you can't see you
got to get another one they could make
the wiper good for 100 years
but they want planned obsolescence the
same thing is happening yeah i guess
trump doesn't realize you just grab a
paper towel you pinch your wiper and
wipe it and then it's like back to new
but you know we we i guess i can't
expect trump to know that so
under a cloud of a criminal federal
investigation against trump he shows up
to deliver what was supposed to be this
historic triumphant defiant principled
speech and he rants about trans athletes
authoritarian wet dreams of sending the
national guard into democratic uh states
and windshield wipers folks
this guy could be the next president
we'll have these clips on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show well as we
increasingly suspected the leak of the
supreme court roe v wade decision
increasingly appears to have been leaked
by right wingers in order to ensure that
roe v wade was overturned we have a new
report from rolling stone it is
absolutely fascinating and we are going
to talk about it but let me kind of
reset the story for you
when that decision leaked
there was the immediate reaction from
the right
that this was a left winger who leaked
the decision to pressure justices to
vote to preserve roe v wade in order to
intimidate them and much of the reason
for that was that left wingers were
rightly outraged that the supreme court
planned to overturn roe v wade so the
right said it was a left winger who did
the leaking we've got to investigate it
we got to figure out who it is people
should be fired disbarred if they're
lawyers whatever
now
i took the approach of
if we're just speculating could have
been a left wing or could have been a
right winger there were two scenarios
one
potential scenario would be
the leaker was on the left
knew that the draft would overturn roe v
wade and thought that by leaking it it
might generate a pressure campaign to
get a supreme court justice or two to
change their minds and vote to preserve
roe v wade
just as plausibly
the leaker could have been a right
winger who was aware that while this
draft would have overturned roe v wade
the february draft that was leaked in
you know a few months after that
they may have known that within the
court
there may have been justices changing
their minds and the idea was to leak the
draft to publicize who as of february
planned to overturn roe v wade to make
it difficult for them to change their
minds these were the two speculative
scenarios and over time as republicans
stopped talking about investigating the
leaker as we heard from longtime supreme
court reporters that within the supreme
court the belief was actually that the
leaker was a right winger i started to
be of the mindset that the leaker was
probably a right winger well we now know
from a new report that that appears to
be correct john roberts was lobbying
kavanaugh to save roe
then the draft opinion leaked a new
report says the leak which conservatives
insist was the work of a rogue liberal
actually helped get row overturned this
was exactly the opinion that i told you
months ago
was the most likely
immediately after the draft supreme
court decision was released
conservatives began bleeding about how
the leak was the work of a nefarious
liberal clerk who wanted to put the
opinion out to pressure the court's
conservatives to change their minds it's
possible that that's what happened but
if so publicizing the draft had the
opposite effect according to a new
report from cnn per the report the leak
of the draft decision foiled chief
justice roberts attempts to persuade
brett kavanaugh to act as roe's saving
vote sources told cnn roberts continued
to try and sway the junior justice even
after the leak of the opinion despite
public and private pressure from
conservatives for the court to solidify
its decision roberts overtures this
spring particularly to kavanaugh raised
fears among conservatives and hopes
among liberals that the chief would
change the outcome in the most closely
watched case in decades now you might
remember
roberts ultimately voted to uphold the
mississippi law that was disputed but he
did a separate
uh concurrence
disagreeing with the decision to strike
down row so i know a lot of you might be
saying but david the math doesn't work
because roberts did vote to uphold dobbs
and the belief is
based on what he wrote and based on
everything that's being reported roberts
wanted to uphold dobbs
but still maintain roe v wade and was
working on kavanaugh to do the same
this is exactly
what it increasingly seemed like within
about eight or ten days of the leaked
decision
and this thinking provides support for
the belief that the leaker was a
right-wing staffer they wanted to
prevent brett kavanaugh from defecting
that's fundamentally what it is and this
is probably why we never heard it how is
the search going for the real killer oj
what do we know right it's the same type
of thing we're going to investigate oh
it was one of ours yeah let's just never
mention that investigation again and
it's very funny and also kind of
disturbing how in the days immediately
following the leak
everybody was saying the the right-wing
apparatus was saying what a travesty
what a miscarriage of justice this is
criminal people need to be charged
people need to be disbarred these
left-wingers leaking this stuff and then
we never hear about it again and to be
perfectly frank the dead giveaway was
that the right and conservative media
went silent about the investigation and
the leaker about a week or 10 days after
the leak took place somebody maybe
tipped them off and said don't don't
even talk about this the leaker was one
of ours or not even just don't talk
about this
don't say more about the investigation
and that's what the report is and it's
exactly what we and many of you believed
at the time
we have some incredible new video of our
friend donnie o'sullivan or do i never
remember if it's donnie or donio
sullivan he's a cnn reporter he's
excellent
he went to arizona over the weekend now
in arizona over the weekend there were
two different things going on one
vice pres former vice president mike
pence was campaigning for the challenger
to carry lake i forget the that
candidate's name
and uh donald trump was campaigning for
kerry lake
tony o'sullivan went
to arizona
interviewed the trump supporters
and it is as bad as anything that i have
ever seen let's take a look at it he
didn't lose
sensitive
he just didn't lose it do you believe
the election was stolen
yes your face in elections now
no
do you believe the 2020 election was was
stolen
uh no i don't believe the 2020 election
was stolen i believe that there are
aspects of the 2020 election that were
unfair in arizona a republican party at
odds with itself trump and pence holding
competing events with two very different
understandings of reality we need a
landslide so big
that the radical left cannot rig it or
steal it even if they try at trump's
rally a bonfire of conspiracy theories
have you ever watched january 6 hearings
i have what do you think
i think they're a bunch of bull
why
well because do you have both sides or
are you getting one side of the story
you mean like the side that attacked the
capital
you really believed that happened
i was there okay
i have a lot of people that were there
guys she has people and and saw things
that it wasn't what they say it was but
there's been hundreds of trump
supporters now
charged
guilty so and do you think it's right
for those people
to have those people in jail and not get
any justice in our
american system all of a sudden you know
it's funny there's been no greater event
that has inspired the right to demand
criminal justice reform
uh pre-trial detention reform there's
been nothing it's been 40 years with the
left has been talking about this and all
of a sudden
these arguably domestic terrorists are
arrested and jailed and now all of a
sudden the right is saying we're not
treating people in the justice system
very well incredible
do you think it was right that they
attacked the capital i don't they didn't
nobody attacked it guys it's all fake
the inside job buddy the vast conspiracy
theory that those who stormed the
capital were not trump supporters is
widespread here have you guys been
watching the january 6 hearings at all
no no
no we saw it when it all went down and
then we saw like a lot of the blm and
the antifa people in the building as
well it was antrifa well
and and it's just it's just nonsense but
i think like 800 people now have been
charged right oh yeah and number black
lives matter are antifa
yeah they're not charging them
we have not been brought into court
right so here's what happened
the real perpetrators of the january 6
riots were black lives matter and antifa
in disguise as trump supporters
they have not actually been charged the
people that have been charged are the
real trump supporters who didn't do
anything but okay they're on video doing
stuff but they're actually black lives
matter
not really trump supporters but the
black lives matter people haven't been
charged and the ones charged are the
trump supporters who are victims
but it looks like they're on video doing
stuff but it's not really trump
supporters it's antifa you see how it's
just an endless circle this circle never
ends
it's like a mobius strip due process
because they have not been arrested
hunter biden hasn't been arrested
trump has told lies about the election
in that
he said he didn't really lose do you
think that all the lies about the
election are damaging for american
democracy
you believe he lied
do you not no i do not i don't why he
won but these are no longer fringe ideas
a majority of republicans do not believe
biden legitimately won the election hey
guys any of you want to talk to us the
proud boys who trump once infamously
told to stand back and stand by now a
regular fixture outside his events like
any pro boys want to talk to us today
no
you've been watching january 6th
hearings
no nothing to say there's nothing that
you're seeing right cnn yeah thank you
not friends okay thanks guys thank you
the former president here to campaign
for a ticket of conspiracy theory
spouting candidates who say they would
have overturned the results of the 2020
election in arizona like carrie lake
candidate for governor i know for a fact
we will no longer accept rigged
elections who's with me on that
right here campaigning for lakes
republican rival arizona needs karen
taylor robson in the state house here we
met some republicans who are done with
trump now here this is also interesting
because it's not like these are
reasonable people but they've had it
with trump i voted for trump twice
if uh mike pence runs i'm voting for
mike pence okay so why is that
i just think that you know everyone's
seen the january 6 committee uh
he stood up for democracy that day you
know he's like i'm not leaving the
capitol because
um i need to be here and he was the one
that was making phone calls through the
military yeah so this is fascinating
because i'm with you that compared to
the trump people this guy seems
eminently reasonable but remember pence
didn't really do anything pence didn't
have a choice
the thing that trump wanted pence to do
pence didn't have the power to do
so now they're considering pence a hero
simply because he didn't overtly try to
do something he had no right to do and
that seems reasonable by comparison
trying to fix the situation while trump
was crying in the dining room but even
among this crowd there is sympathy for
trump's election lies and support for a
2024 run you're about to see pence speak
here uh trump's not a big fan of him
right now i understand that
i hear that he could have not certified
those results pending all the claims of
the fraud and i wish he would have done
that pence had no legal basis to do that
also among those here rusty bowers a
lifelong republican and speaker of the
arizona state house
we're talking to a lot of people in here
today who said they're not even
they're not watching the january 6th
hearings they still believe
that lies about the 2020 election how do
you what would be your message to them
i i have no message for him i can't help
him if you don't want to look you don't
want to see and then you won't see
you know but
i've seen enough to know
and i know that all the people right in
this room have done their best to count
everything and do it all right he
testified before the january 6 committee
about trump's efforts to get him to
overturn the 2020 results in his state
what is these conspiracy theories these
lies
about the election about democracy what
is that doing to trust
in this state it destroys it
it destroys it we've got to let things
go what would need to change for you to
have faith
in u.s democracy
i don't trust our government first of
all period and if you don't have fair
elections what good are they do you ever
worry that you're wrong do you ever
worry that oh absolutely
you ever worry that maybe trump has sold
you a lie
if you start researching and believe
that you're the one who's wrong and that
you're crazy which i did do thinking
okay maybe i'm wrong and maybe i am
being brainwashed and believing
something that someone's telling me but
then you go in and look the other
direction and you find lies after lies
after lies right she suspected she was
being lied to but then she's like the
other side is lying even more i guess so
this is
these are very resistant to change
beliefs
and there is going to be a real battle
for the republican party if you look at
the polling you already see it and we're
going to look at some of that polling
later this week probably or maybe next
week
this is going to be a real battle in not
only 22 but in particular in 2024 but
look at the folks that are being fought
over and that really should make us
think wow
this is not exactly a group to put it
politely
that is necessarily going to fairly and
soberly and calmly
evaluate the claims being my being made
by the trump and anti-trump sides of the
republican party and come to some kind
of empirical conclusion uh and that
should scare all of us we're going to
continue covering these types of
interviews really really good job there
by donio sullivan
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
all right we suspected this would happen
and now they are being very clear that
it's going to happen if republicans take
control of the house at minimum in
november they are going to launch a
massive show investigation of dr anthony
fauci yes dr anthony fauci who is now uh
what he's 81 or how old is he now 81
years old is going to be 82 years old in
a few months retiring
he is going to be investigated by
republicans
if they take control of the house the
hill has an article about it gop plots
fauci probe after midterms one way or
another if we are in the majority we
will subpoena his records and he will
testify in the senate under oath so rand
paul on the senate side saying we are
going to investigate in the senate uh
marjorie taylor greene and many others
have said we are going matt gates we are
going to investigate in the house uh
rand paul says if we win november and
i'm chairman of a committee if i have
subpoena power we'll go after every one
of fouchy's records now we do need
investigations related to uh covid and
the response we we do
but the investigations we need
are into
the lack of preparation by the united
states trump throwing out the pandemic
pandemic response uh playbook and
disbanding the pandemic response team
uh the way in which medical
professionals were ignored from day one
by the the then trump administration all
of those things do deserve an
investigation and we should have an
investigation into anti-vax as well as
other disinformation propaganda content
that was disseminated
investigating fauci
and the reason they hate fauci is fauci
was willing to stand right next to trump
during those early press conferences in
the pandemic remember i would cover
those and just tell the medical truth
about the virus that everybody needed to
hear
and he was more trusted than trump on
those issues and so trump couldn't fire
him dr deborah burks on the other hand
while she sometimes would say things
that were more or less true
uh was very very willing to
more or less
mold her views to what donald trump
wanted them to be
and dr fauci
gave the best advice that the facts
pointed to at the time it exposed trump
to be this sort of sideshow dishonest
liar who not only didn't seem to
understand what was going on
really only cared about getting himself
elected and trump ended up vilifying dr
fauci and this is another reminder by
the way of just how incompetently trump
was from a political standpoint in
handling the pandemic because donald
trump i've said this before
trump could have treated covid like 911
or like pearl harbor
and he could have come and said
the amer to the american people
this is going to be difficult this is
going to be difficult for the planet and
it's going to be difficult for the
united states
we have the top experts i am completely
confident in their ability to lead us
i'm going to be deferring to the experts
we will be masking everyone up with mega
masks
and we are going right you you get the
idea uh and then swoop in and take the
credit and he would have sailed to an
easy re-election and a lot of people
constantly say trump only lost the
election because of the bad luck of the
pandemic
wrong
wrong the pandemic was an event that
could either destroy you or it could
rocket you to reelection and we saw that
in new zealand and in some other places
when leaders were seen as competently
and efficiently and prudently handling
the pandemic well they were very much
rewarded with high approval ratings uh
as well as sometimes re-election this
could have been a layup for trump if he
sold the maga masks and said we've got
the best experts and look at how
patriotic i am i'm protecting everybody
around me he would have easily been
re-elected and there's a very
interesting article i encourage you to
check out
uh let me see what year it's from it's
in the daily beast it's from uh oh no
it's a new article it's called the four
stages of republican misinformation and
it explains how it works and the article
says quote
first republicans use any means means
necessary to achieve power and promote
their
counter-majoritarian agenda remember the
the modern american right-wing
supports ideas that aren't very popular
with the american people the party the
republican party is very much against
abortion the american people are mostly
in favor of it and there's many other
examples that's step one step two they
create and promote disinformation and
lies to frighten their base and to sort
of trick them into believing that they
are being oppressed by the people who
are actually the victims and we saw this
before the doctors are going to oppress
you be afraid of this mandate and that
mandate and this jab and
magnetized arms from the vaccine and all
this different stuff
third they create a villain that they
can target and attack
they scapegoat them they smear them they
intimidate them they did that with
fouchy and then the fourth step is never
back down never apologize instead double
down when their lies are exposed and
then pivot towards more fear-mongering
if you can throw in racism or xenophobia
uh that's also a staple and that is how
the republican misinformation works it's
what they're doing to fauci and it's
going to continue
hey this you have to see
one of the hosts of the conspiracy right
wing disinformation network oan one
america news her name is alison
steinberg she has started to desperately
plead with liberals to help save oan why
do they need to be saved well because
one american news is now getting dumped
massive dumps by verizon which is the
only major carrier it had left we
covered when directv dropped oan
i believe we covered when a t
dropped oan
uh yes the
t
spinoff decided not to renew its
contract with oan
oan sued and now verizon says we are
dropping oan as well so here is allison
steinberg pleading and saying hey we
need to come together on this we need to
we need liberals to help save us but it
is absolutely crucial that for once we
defy the powers that be that we all come
together set aside our differences in a
unified effort so that we can recognize
the horrifying danger that lies ahead if
you're watching this and you're laughing
and scoffing because you think that
you're immune to what's coming you just
wait enjoy your freedoms while you still
got them
but for anyone that's with me and is
willing to contribute to fighting this
beast here is what you need to do right
if you're ready to send money folks now
[ __ ] this is a horrible person and this
is not about just defending diversity of
views and media allison steinberg was
gleeful when biden got coveted she
pushed all sorts of different conspiracy
theories she said she was being
controlled through her nest thermostat
or something like that uh homophobia
harassment anti-mask tantrums she
celebrated when dr fauci got coveted she
lamented that he was probably going to
recover she referred to the covid
vaccine for kids as poison she said only
doctors benefit from the vaccines she
interviewed known homophobic antisemite
kyle clifton and uh treated it like he
was a serious person worthy of listening
to his ideas she often would use social
media to encourage the harassment of
specific people she called those who
work at disney pedophiles get the hell
out of here alison this is called the
free market
i support a diversity of ideas
and uh i support the reality that
businesses can decide who they want to
be in business with and if verizon says
it's not good for our business to have
oan on our platform then that is their
decision to make and normally people
like allison steinberg are defending it
not decrying it so no alison i'm not
going to donate to oan so that you can
stay on the air and target people and
bully people and spread this information
if there is a
if there is a a demand i guess i would
say for that
i'm sure that you can resurface on
uh youtube or your own website or
whatever they may even be banned from
youtube i don't remember now but this is
called the free market of ideas and it's
supply and demand and it seems like the
demand for her nonsense is not as high
as maybe she would like to believe we
have a voicemail number and that number
is 219 to david p
increasingly people in the audience are
very concerned about my pillow ceo mike
lindell's health we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines we
have all noticed that he seems
particularly hopped up lately and here
is a caller who says pillow is sick
pillow is sick
hi david in lieu of last night's um
hopefully one of the final hearings of
january 6
i was hoping that you might really go a
little bit lighter on mike lindell the
man is ill
and i don't want to see him harm himself
and we need to be as compassionate as we
can for him hopefully he's going to
realize what's going on and he's going
to do a big 180
and i think the man's gonna need support
uh well
the country has actually made fun of him
for snapping and uh we need to shape up
as human beings and realize that he's
one of us
in spite of the fact we're he's just
sick and we need to take care of him
thanks bye there is no question
whatsoever that something is very wrong
with mike pillow now there has been
speculation that he's back on drugs i
don't know if that's the case it's not
funny it's sad it's a medical problem
and he needs help
uh there is speculation that
this insanity over the last two years of
flying all around the country to every
trump rally and doing his symposium and
all of these different things has just
strained his relationship with his
family and that that's kind of uh what
we are seeing something is very clearly
wrong with the guy and early on we would
wonder does mike pillow believe this
stuff or doesn't he and at first i
thought at first i thought it was sort
of an act
it doesn't seem like an act at this
point and i interviewed him and i
interacted with him a little bit behind
the scenes and also saw how he interacts
with his staff
something seems off with the guy so
listen i hope he gets the help that he
needs uh we will to the extent that he
still has a following
i mean listen what as i've said before
when you've got a crazy guy yelling in
the subway
and they don't have the following to
become president or become adjacent to
the president you don't think about it
too much
when you have a country that will see a
guy who is so obviously unhinged
and say this guy is a genius this guy's
going to save us and then the former
president invites him to his rallies or
maybe he's not invited but welcomed and
shouted out
then you say it's more about the
followers than it is the guy and that
certainly seems to be the case with mike
pillow so hopefully he gets the help he
needs seems like it's a lot of it we
have a great bonus show planned for you
today a republican lawmaker
voted against same-sex marriage
and then three days later went to his
gay son's gay wedding
what
yeah
russia says it will quit the
international space station after 2024
and the teen activist who was body
shamed by republican congressman matt
gates has received more than 28 thousand
dollars in donations for her work
three incredible stories all on today's
bonus show you can sign up at join
joinpackman.com get instant access
we will see you then